baby fait ce challenge était chroniqueur
je vous montrais des chroniques et on
aime le dire à votre ami de qui il
s'agit quand il était petit regard des
premières photos je connais connaissant
la régie vont mettre le nom en dessous
[Rires]
alors l'église c'est qui ça c'est qui ça
alors c'est qu'ils attendent voie pavée
on arrive c'est benhaim cebenna il n'y
aura rien mais regardez que m regardez
15-4 menacer le nez à cette histoire
jamais non c'est moins cher et je viens
de dire que c'est castaldi mais elle est
possible j'allais encore sur chérie fm
ça la regarde et cast castaldi et mais
benjamin qu'est ce que t'es mignon mais
il est trop chou belge thébaux r est
situé que tu expliques à l'époque les
histoires des doliprane oui mais
j'espère que mon petit qui arrive sera
aussi beau que celui là franchement
c'est mathieu j'espère qu'ils le savent
alors s'il vous plaît c'est encore
castaldi troubler
regardez on va je veux pas qu'on mette
je veux qu'on mette sophie cost
maintenant sophie cost sophie cost
regarder on va la voir tout de suite
quand elle était jeune plus jeune sophie
call alouettes avaient déjà assuré qu'il
faisait du premier mec tu avais déjà
pêche au thon premier mec au nom non
j'avais j'avais non j'avais embrassé
mais j'avais acheté par louis embrasse
et avait déjà embrassé mon prénom c'est
oui on sait pas assez oui on fait rouler
ses shows pécho ça veut dire juste
embrassés à l'embrasser à roulettes à
première pelle en cm2 en cm2 j'avais un
amoureux ce alors qu'eric était trop
mignon mais il m'arrivait la whey iront
alors il se mettait sur le trottoir et
moi je me mettais dans le caniveau et on
se levait des bisous à la bike débat
vous voyez la minière c'est fou et il
est toujours sur le trottoir sache que
je les croise ayant des comptes
ah ah
il avait toujours la robe et la
moustache on va jouer convoi matthieu
delormeau matthieu delormeau regard des
matchs de langoat magnifique boîtier de
lambres matthieu delormeau
oh là là et il est beau gosse il est
beau gosse jouant chez mes sept ans la
scène sept ans non c'est vrai les frères
en direct on a 22 à huy
non pas parce que c'était très mûr
j'étais en fait j'ai été diagnostiquée
surdoué mais peu importe on école à
témoin c'est là à mon avis les mecs qui
ont diagnostiqué c'est les mêmes mecs
qui disait que le courant n'a virus
était une grippette et poitou histoires
pressées grand retard et du coup ma mère
m'appelait cailloux stukus parce que
j'étais tout petit et du coup à l'école
j'ai toujours celui qui étaient plus
petits de la classe et qui indiquaient
qu'ils prenaient à galway et et april a
poussé d'un coup tu peux nous rappeler
combien tu mesures mathieu aux mots pas
très grand je vais 1 m 84 non plus que
farrell kg tu fais un mètre 86 87 je
pense non j'aurais deuxième tu vois là
tu sais là mais tu sais que tu veux la
vérité c'est horrible la vieillesse je
me suis tassé
j'ai perdu 2 cm a dit le médecin non
mais de taille ou de dans le script
parce que ça c'est pas la vieillesse
sinon c'est quelque chose qui a mal
tourné les cherry on a également gilles
verdez six rallyes pour le plaisir
gilles verdez regarder est toujours
bonne à celui ci depuis petit regardez
qu'est ce qu'il est beau ouais bah oui
bah c'est normal c'est beau et un animal
photos de gilles verdez mais nous trop
tôt jean hamon le voit très loin des
frères on dirait des jeunes en fonction
celle là est ça aussi c'est gilles
verdez gilles vraiment à toi tu as
vraiment a eu c'est vraiment ton
physique est un long fleuve tranquille